♫
♫ ♫
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW FOR A
RARE EXCLUSIVE ONE-ON-ONE
INTERVIEW, SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
PRESIDENT, THAT WOULD BE JARED
KUSHNER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU HATE DOING THESE INTERVIEWS.
I DO NOT BLAME YOU, WHO WOULD
WANT TO COME ON AND DO THIS?
>> IT IS GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
SEAN.
>> Sean: A LOT GOING ON AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, LET’S START WITH
THE NEWS PAID A NEW AG COMING
IN, WE ARE WAITING AN FOR CHIEF
OF STAFF.
OBVIOUSLY TWO YEARS OF THE
MUELLER PROBE HANGING OVER
EVERYBODY’S HEAD.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE PRESSURE IS
RATCHETING UP.
WHAT IS IT LIKE INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
CHANGES?
>> I WANT TO START BY THINKING
GENERAL KELLY FOR HIS GREAT
SERVICE TO THIS ADMINISTRATION,
GENERAL KELLY HAS SERVED THE
STATE FOR 40 YEARS, AND VERY
HELPFUL TO THE PRESIDENT TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTING A LOT OF THE
IMPORTANT PARTS OF HIS
SUCCESSFUL AGENDA.
SO I WANT TO START WITH THAT.
THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW THAT
BROUGHT A NEW WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL WHO JUST STARTED AND
IT’S GOING TO BE FABULOUS, THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THE PICK FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO WILL BE
GOOD AS WELL FROM WHAT I AM
SEEING.
AND RIGHT NOW THE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING ALONG AND
THE PRESIDENT WON’T MAKE THE
RIGHT CHOICE OF CHIEF OF STAFF.
IF CHOOSING SOMEONE HE HAS A
GREAT CHEMISTRY WITH, WHO WILL
HELP HIM NAVIGATE THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS THROUGH ALL OF
THE GOOD OPPORTUNITIES TO KEEP
PUSHING FORWARD.
>> Sean: 30 YEARS IN RADIO, 23
YEARS AS A FOX NEWS CHANNEL, FOR
EXAMPLE, NEWS CAME OUT TODAY
THE U.S. IS NOW AN OIL EXPORTING
THAT NOBODY WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
NATION FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
SEVEN YEARS.
ADD THAT TO ALL OF THE OTHER
ECONOMIC SUCCESS AND FOREIGN
POLICY SUCCESS, YOU DO NOT HEAR
ABOUT IT.
YOU ARE INSIDE THAT WHITE HOUSE.
IF YOU TURN ON THE TV, YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU WILL HEAR EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY DAY, HOW
DOES THAT IMPACT YOU AND THE
REST OF THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> I THINK THAT THERE IS A LARGE
PART OF THE WHITE HOUSE THAT IT
DOES NOT IMPACT THAT MUCH PAID
WE KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS
TO GET THROUGH, HE IS CLEAR WHAT
OUR OBJECTIVES ARE.
OUR JOB IS TO COME IN EVERY DAY
AND FOCUS ON THOSE GOALS AND
KEEP MOVING ALONG.
NOBODY SAW THESE NUMBERS COMING
IN TERMS OF THE OIL EXPERTS AND
HOW WE WERE GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA AN INDEPENDENT COUNTRY,
BUT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
THAT HAS BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF
GREAT WORK OF A LOT OF THE
CABINET SECRETARIES, BUT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PRESIDENT TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF STORIES I
GET A LOT OF ATTENTION IN THE
NEWS, BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PHENOMENAL PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO SHOW UP TO
WORK EVERY DAY IGNORING THE
NOISE THAT IS OUT THERE AND JUST
FOCUSING ON HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH
THE OBJECTIVES OF THE PRESIDENT
WHICH IS TO MAKE OUR COUNTRY OR
PROSPEROUS, INCREASED WAGES FOR
PEOPLE, CREATE MORE JOBS AND
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE ISSUES,
YOU WORK ON SPECIFIC ISSUES, I
WILL ASK YOU ABOUT THE
MIDDLE EAST.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT, BUT I WANT TO
GET INTO THE ISSUE A PRISON
REFORM.
I THINK ONE OF THE GREATEST
MOMENTS IN THE PRESIDENT’S
HISTORY, HE COMMUTES A SENTENCE
OF A WOMAN BY ALICE MARIE
JOHNSON.
I’D A CHANCE TO INTERVIEW HER,
AND WE HAVE THIS VIDEO OF HER
AFTER WHAT 20 YEARS IN JAIL, ONE
DRUG OFFENSE, IT WAS SERIOUS,
BUT ONE.
AND SHE COMES OUT AND I WILL
NEVER FORGET WHAT SHE SAID, SHE
SAID THANK YOU, AMERICA,
THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU WANT TO REGRET GIVING A
SECOND CHANCE.
AND THERE IS A BIG PRISON REFORM
BILL, AND I KNOW THAT YOU’RE
SPEARHEADING IT IN TERMS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN
RELUCTANCE AND RESISTANCE,
ESPECIALLY MITCH McCONNELL IN
THE SENATE AND OTHERS, MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS, WHY IT IS,
WHAT TO DO WE NEED TO DO WHEN
YOU HAVE A 77% RECIDIVISM RATE,
AND -- ARE WE LOCKING PEOPLE UP
BUT NOT EQUIPPING THEM TO MEET
THE CHALLENGES WHEN THEY FINALLY
GET OUT?
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM?
>> SO THIS BILL WILL ACCOMPLISH
A LOT TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER, THE RECIDIVISM RATE THAT
WE HAVE IS WAY TOO HIGH.
NOT DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THAT IS
IRRESPONSIBLE.
WE ARE ALLOWING PEOPLE TO GO
BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES WE CAN
HELP.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF PROGRAMS
BASED IN RED STATES THAT WE HAVE
REALLY MODELED US OFF OF.
WE KNOW THAT THIS WORKS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD A
VERY STRONG BIPARTISAN COALITION
VERY STRONG BIPARTISAN COALITIONUNDER THE PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP
UNDER THE PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP
TO COME UP WITH A BILL THAT WE
THINK CAN REALLY SOLVE A LOT OF
THOSE PROBLEMS.
AND WHAT IT IS IS GOING INTO THE
PRISONS AND GIVING JOB TRAINING,
VOCATIONAL TRAINING.
MENTORSHIP, MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT, DRUG ADDICTION
TREATMENT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING OUT TO HER NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS AND FIGURING OUT HOW
WHEN THEY LEAVE PRISON THEY HAVE
A BETTER CHANCE OF GETTING A JOB
IN REENTERING SOCIETY IN A
PRODUCTIVE MANNER THAN GOING
BACK TO A LIFE OF CRIME.
THESE REFORMS ARE BASED ON WHAT
HAS WORKED AND IT WILL MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
SO THE PRESIDENT HAS BUILT AN
AMAZING BIPARTISAN COALITION OF
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, AND
WE ARE VERY CLOSE RIGHT NOW, AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL GET TO THE
FLOOR AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HAVE A BIG BIPARTISAN
CELEBRATION BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
>> Sean: VIOLENT OFFENDERS,
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT YOU CANNOT
LET OUT.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO
SERVE THEIR TERM, BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND I DO THINK THAT THERE
HAS BEEN DISPROPORTIONATE
SENTENCING, ESPECIALLY FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE CRACKER AND
POWDER COCAINE ISSUE, THAT IS
BEEN PROVEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN
PRAYED I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT.
AND I DON’T KNOW IF THIS PART OF
THE PACKAGE TRANSFORM THE POWER
OF THE PARDON.
PUT UP COMMITTEES, FIND THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WE REALLY BELIEVE
HAVE A VERY LOW CHANCE OF
RECIDIVISM, ONE TIME OFFENDERS
LIKE ALICE MARIE JOHNSON AND
FIND THEM ALL AND LET THEM --
GIVE THEM ANOTHER CHANCE WITH
CERTAIN CONDITIONS, PERHAPS.
>> THIS BILL DOES PART OF THAT,
AND IT RINGS ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT INMATES WHO ARE IN THE
FEDERAL PRISON SYSTEM UNDER A
LIKELIHOOD OF COMMITTING A CRIME
IN THE FUTURE.
AND IT ALLOWS US TO FOCUS ON THE
NONVIOLENT PEOPLE WHO HAVE A LOW
RISK, SOMEBODY LIKE ALICE MARIE
JOHNSON, THAT CASE WAS A GRAVE
MISTRUST US.
AND THE PRESIDENT DID A GREAT
JOB OF WRITING THAT WRONG.
THAT CASE REALLY TOUCHED HIS
HEART AND THAT WAS SOMETHING
WHERE HE REALIZED THAT THERE WAS
NO REASON FOR TAXPAYERS TO BE
PAYING TO HOW SOMEBODY LIKE
ALICE WHEN SHE COULD BE OUT IN
SOCIETY AND BE A GOOD ROLE MODEL
FOR OTHERS.
TAKING THE MISTAKES THAT SHE
MADE AND FIGURING OUT HOW TO
SHOW OTHER PEOPLE HOW TO NOT TO
MAKE THOSE SAME MISTAKES.
WE HAVE A GREAT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY, IT IS THE
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY, IT IS THEBEST IN THE WORLD, BUT STILL FAR
BEST IN THE WORLD, BUT STILL FAR
FROM PERFECT.
THE BILL WOULD DO A LOT TO
CORRECT SOME RACIAL DISPARITIES.
>> Sean: CAN WE SAVE MONEY?
CAN WE SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY IN
THE PROCESS?
>> ABSOLUTELY, WE ARE PUTTING
TOO MUCH MONEY TOWARDS
WAREHOUSING PEOPLE THAT WE DO
NOT NEED TO BE WAREHOUSING, IT
SHOULD BE GOING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE FRONT
LINES KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFE.
AND AS WE DO THIS RIGHT IT HAS
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE REPUBLICAN
STATES, ABLE TO REDUCE CRIME AND
COST.
WHICH IS WHY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS GOOD.
AGAIN THIS IS A POLICY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BRING A LOT OF
SMART PEOPLE TOGETHER, WE HAVE A
GREAT COALITION, AND THE REASON
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT IS
BECAUSE IT IS A DATA-DRIVEN
MODEL AND IT IS BASED ON THINGS
THAT WORK AND HAVE WORKED BEFORE
THAT WORK AND HAVE WORKED BEFOR
BEFORE.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION,
ANOTHER AREA THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
INTERESTED IN IS THE
MIDDLE EAST, YOU HAVE BEEN ON A
NUMBER OF TRIPS, YOU HAVE IN THE
JORDAN, EGYPT, ISRAEL,
SAUDI ARABIA.
YOU HAVE TALKED ALL THESE
PEOPLE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A MOMENT
WHERE THERE IS A NEW ALLIANCE OR
COALITION EMERGING AGAINST A
GEMINI AND NUCLEAR ARMED IRAN,
HAS THAT PROCESS BEEN HURT AS A
RESULT OF THE JAMAAL KHASHOGGI
KILLING, AND KNOW THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING HELD
RESPONSIBLE, AND DO YOU FEEL
THAT WE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT IF WE HAVE NOT ALREADY.
>> I THINK THAT OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES ARE MAKING ASSESSMENTS
AND WE ARE HOPING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS JUSTICE BROUGHT TO
WHERE THAT SHOULD BE, WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE BROADER REGION
WHICH IS FIGURING OUT HOW TO
HOPEFULLY BRING A DEAL TOGETHER
BETWEEN THE ISRAELIS AND THE
PALESTINIANS.
THAT CONFLICT HAS GONE ON FOR
WAY TOO LONG.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON TRYING TO BRING ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PARTIES TOGETHER.
WE ARE HOPEFUL IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS WE WILL PUT OUT
OUR PLAN WHICH NOT EVERY SIDE
WILL LOVE, BUT THERE IS ENOUGH
REASONS WHY PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE
IT AND MOVE FORWARD.
THIS PLAN WILL KEEP THE ISRAELI
PEOPLE SAFE, GIVE THEM A GOOD
FUTURE, BUT ALSO GIVE A REAL
OPPORTUNITY AND HOPE FOR THE
PALESTINIAN PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
CAN LIVE MUCH BETTER LIVES.
I’VE BEEN SAYING A LOT THAT YOU
SHOULD NOT BE HIJACKING YOUR
CHILDREN’S FUTURE BECAUSE OF
YOUR GRANDPARENTS CONFLICT.
AND THIS IS A CONFLICT THAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR WAY TOO LONG.
AND THE WAY THE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN GAZA AND WEST BANK
RIGHT NOW IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND THERE IS A LOT THAT WE COULD
BE DOING TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE, BUT IT COMES WITH
RESOLVING SOME OF THE CORE
ISSUES.
IT IS NOT JUST THE ARREARS
ISRAELIS OR PALESTINIAN PEOPLE,
IT IS ALL OF THE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
MIDDLE EAST WHO WOULD LIKE TO SE
MIDDLE EAST WHO WOULD LIKE TO ST